plus fort que des chiens d'avalanche qui
sauvent des vies humaines moins stupide
que le chien de pompiers qui creuse le
sable pour prouver blot plus sympathique
le chien taxi qui mord le client qui
n'ont pas la monnaie voici le chien de
médecins mieux connue sous son nom
vulgaire d'hippocrate poil dur
alors comment ça va ce matin d'internât
morts doucement doucement vous trouvez
pas touché pas touchés par ces mots fini
mon fond de teint pour lâcher c'est très
bien c'est bruce qui sont certes de ces
play offs et mieux alors c'est bon la
provence 35 maintenant vous allez dire
30 points il ya vous asseyez oui 10 33
eh bien je suis très heureuse d'avoir
l'occasion de donner simplement de 33
des 33 je me sens que je ne sens pas je
ne sens pas docteur 28 si vous voulez
donner lambert 28 ans cela intéresse pas
du tout peur vous n'avez pas écouté tous
les matins c'est le même problème celui
ci je veux se passait réellement devenir
trop mignon je ne les sens pas je
n'hésiterais pas fait je sens que je
peux pas faire ce n'est pas finalisé par
bonheur n'avait pas dit à 33 du
programme ils peuvent travailler
médecins français ne manquait plus mon
patient fait des morts par le monde
pourquoi